hey let's face it there's a lot of anger
out there at this moment towards
celebrities why celebrities are posting
videos from their homes and a lot of
them have very beautiful spacious
mansions and they look out of touch
telling us hey chill it's all gonna be
okay
and then you see how they live and it's
just insane I just want to tell all my
celebrity friends be careful about that
okay try and try and just be sensible
about what you show in your home I don't
worry about that I have a simple home a
nice home but a simple home and I'm
proud of it but nothing too opulent okay
now that I got that message across I
want to do something fun today
I've been practicing magic during this
quarantine simple little magic but it's
kind of fun and sweet and I've been
working on something with a trick coin
that I ordered through the mail it's
really fun let me do it for you right
now it's a funny little trick coin bit
you know what I don't know where I left
the coin let me quickly check out in the
hallways an arrant trick coin no way
[Music]
with my claw huh I know where I can
check the bathroom here I had that trick
coin I usually practice on the toilet
maybe I'll check the solarium yes any of
the gardener's see my trick coin I was
going to entertain everybody online I
know the wine cellar hmm smell that oak
I don't see a trick coin but I see the
three barrels I'll be drinking tonight
Who am I kidding four barrels the
falconry Brutus what about you mom
haven't seen my lucky coin you're right
trick coin thank
for correcting me the bank fault well I
don't see it just some loose change the
helipad anyone see my trick coin no no
trip coin maybe it's at the other
helipad
well guess I'll head back to my simple
and humble study yep
couldn't find my trick coin sorry about
that was gonna do a little trick for you
but maybe I'll find it next time
glad you were able to spend these
valuable moments with me and remember
celebrities keep it real